let's do rodney
how am i supposed to follow up aquaman
jesus yeah you're [ __ ] now dude
i know okay so um first of all big fan
of your work uh just initiated a divorce
it was my idea
um
and we were together for a few years
um
awesome chick very sweet giver
good relationship with her parents no
issues there no no no crazy craziness i
just wasn't feeling the passion
i could say
uh during the relationship and
you know i never i'm 31 right now and i
never really had a huge issue uh dating
especially my later 20s when i went
through
all your work you know coach corey wayne
a bunch of different people rolled
tomassie in the sphere i never really
had a problem dating i really mastered
that but
the biggest insecurity in my life i'd
say was just my passion and income and
those sorts of things um so that was
always like a an issue in my life that i
always had trouble addressing and so um
you know when she came along uh on paper
i mean she's good-looking she has a lot
going for her um and she wasn't [ __ ]
she excuse me she wasn't crazy so you
know we dated for a while we broke up a
few times because of the fact that i was
kind of not feeling it i didn't feel the
desire
got married which was a mistake um now
you know now we're getting divorced i'm
in an airbnb while she moves out of my
apartment
um but
so my question is the last six months
have been absolutely insane i started a
youtube channel hopefully people don't
notice this because it's in
cryptocurrency and it's kind of crazy on
uh on twitter and whatnot yeah youtube
i'm just gonna say this guys if you know
if you're on my channel
assume that
people you know will see it right
so
yeah like i mean if you guys want a
private conversation i do private
consults but they're paid i mean like
the deal here is you know you help me
create content by hopping on my show and
i answer your questions
hundred
anyway so okay so you have a youtube
channel things are going good and then
your question again sorry
my question is now that you know i'm
doing well when it comes it comes to
when it comes to uh you know financial
financially now that i'm more
financially stable um how would you go
about navigating the world uh
safeguarding your money um and what what
have you done since you've been you know
um
you ran a bunch of businesses you know
you make a lot of money how do you kind
of navigate the dating world navigate
life right now
as a person who makes a good amount of
money for what he does
yeah well um i don't uh date or spend
plates i got a girlfriend um you know
i've been dealing with her for a few
years now
um she's a good check right you know she
compliments my life doesn't doesn't
compliment uh doesn't doesn't complicate
it i don't i don't have to deal with
picking up cat vomit nobody tells me you
know when or where i can [ __ ] go
anywhere
but i mean a lot of that is
you know like you can attest to
not inviting crazy in your life right i
don't i don't deal with any red flags
you know i don't tolerate nonsense um
like very very compliant
i don't live with her you know we live
in separate you know residences so
i mean like you live in the west
obviously like where do you live
uh california san diego yeah that's a
[ __ ] hostile state you know towards
men so it's like as soon as you live
with a checkers or start living in a way
that looks like marriage or or common
law then you're inviting the state to
decide
what happens to
that relationship if you have to split
it up so
you know
to the point of your question like what
do you do to protect yourself the
simplest thing is don't live with a
woman
right i mean you said that you've got
kids like you're getting divorced no no
no no i don't have kids or anything like
that no okay so
okay how old are you
i'm 31. do you want to have kids
eventually but you know now that i found
this passion dude all i want to do is
work all day to be honest
move out of california the their their
states like
i had a guy on at the start of january
um i can't remember his name right now
or what the title the show was but it
was on an unplugged alpha
podcast so i mean you can go look back
about five months but essentially the
the best states for shared parenting or
for fathers you know specifically
um were
whatever state nashville is in its uh
tennessee right ncea yeah so it was
tennessee arizona texas and florida but
i think tennessee was right at the top
so
if you want to have kids and live in the
united states i would i would move to
one of those states you know whichever
one is most appealing to you that has
the best tax rate
maybe closest to family or any one of
those things matter
but
to do that in california like you're
like you're asking me a legit question
is how do i not [ __ ] up my life now that
i'm successful
and like the first thing i would tell
you is don't live with a check don't
live in a way that the state can view as
marriage and if you do decide to have
kids do it in a state that's not going
to [ __ ] you up because 50 of the time um
you're going to get divorced and it's
not going to be nice and it's going to
cost you a lot of money and you're going
to struggle to see your own children
make decisions around them so
again you know if if if that's part of
the plan long term go to a state that's
friendlier to men
got it okay because i mean like you can
work anywhere in the world right like
why would you pay huge taxes in
california
i love the beach but i mean it's
beautiful out here but you know the
politics are a little crazy and i'm in
the i'm in the reserve too so i just
can't up and leave but
um i like the beach man i'm just stuck
here you know because i just love the i
love the vibe i don't like the people
necessarily or the politics
but
i feel like sometimes you got to fight
the battle on the home front but if it
comes to safeguarding wealth and those
sorts of things then i don't consider
florida so i want you to pay attention
to what you just said there you said i
feel like okay
and i've noticed a lot a lot of this
lately over the last couple of months is
that when
women speak they usually start sentences
and in conversations with i feel like
soy boys beta males also start sentences
with i feel like
thinkers rational men that are unplugged
start sentences with i think
okay so you're still kind of leaning
into like an emotional side of yourself
it's like i you know i feel like this
that any other thing and you know i'm
going to complicate my life and justify
why and that's why i'm here sort of
thing
right but once you start thinking right
like once you i think
you know you start catching yourself
using sentences like that then you're
going to be like
peaches are nice but you know what
uh they have beaches in florida
right yeah and that's a friendlier state
to fathers and the tax rate's pretty
good and it's more of a red state than a
stupid blue state and i'm not going to
deal with so many like left-leaning you
know purple hair pronoun people with i
stand with whatever new country that
happens to be the hot thing right now
right
yeah
yeah
so okay again i mean you know everybody
wants a quick and easy like you know
wave the magic wand and solve my problem
how do i protect my assets well this is
one of the things that you're gonna have
to come to grips with is
california's a bad place for men
bottom line i mean i have friends there
that have been through the divorce
grinder like um aubry huff mlb uh you
know baseball player two uh world series
championships he's stuck in california
because he's divorced and he's raising
his kids there and you know his
ex-wife's there right um
he had a lot of money and had a very
successful career and losing half of it
didn't you know destroy his world and
he's been public about it i mean i've
had him on my channel a couple times
right but um you know if you have the
choice to go somewhere else i mean you
ask guys like that and you set them down
one after the other you talk to a dozen
of them you talk to two dozen you talk
to three three dozen they'll all say the
same thing get the [ __ ] out you know
like why would you
build something on
a shaky foundation that's potentially
hazardous when you could do it somewhere
else that's a lot less risky
you know again the theme of the show
again right
simplify your life right oh comes razor
that you know the simplest explanation
is the most correct one
right that's the easiest way to like you
know define this entire show is you know
what you need to do it's like okay well
that means i have to pick up [ __ ] well
i'm in the reserves and i can't i kind
of have enough time here and i like the
beach it's like okay
don't don't come crying to me in 10
years when you marry some chick and she
takes your kids you don't see them
yeah and and like you know you guys have
been married for a certain period of
time that the state's now saying [ __ ]
you you have to pay alimony for the rest
of your life
all right man i appreciate it you can
kiss that crypto goodbye or i know
you're [ __ ] telling me yeah desantis
is pretty sweet so i like desantis or
you can put all this [ __ ] on your ledger
hop on a plane and fly over to puerto
rico or florida or wherever the [ __ ] you
want right there
that's right man wait how do you [ __ ]
you know i got your word on there
all right take care
you